[Musica]
quanti di voi sono stati in biblioteca
almeno una volta nella vita per alzata
di mano
grandioso
diventa più difficile adesso negli
ultimi sei mesi
difficilissimo nell'ultima settimana
io sono fra i pochi io lavoro in
biblioteca per cui capite
allora vi facciamo da capo se io dovessi
chiedervi questa cosa tirate fuori una
sola parola dalla pancia
se vi dico biblioteca che cosa
immaginate
tutti i libri spazio
relax
meraviglia siete tutti bravi di solito a
questa domanda rispondono in modo
completamente diverso e si schierò
l'iniquità delle nelle parole in realtà
voi sapete benissimo che
l'opinione comune ormai il senso comune
della parola biblioteca viene associata
piuttosto ancora ad un livello di
tristezza e qualche cosa di telethon
tetro grigio e anche silenzioso e non
solo ma le biblioteche ormai vengono
considerate quasi come inattuali perché
ormai ci sono i motori di ricerca
a che cosa servono le biblioteche ma
invece non è così non è proprio così o
almeno non dovrebbe esserlo e potrebbe
essere qualche cosa di diverso
vi racconto una storia nella primavera
del 2014 arrivo in biblioteca da noi la
presidente di uno degli impianti delle
società di impianti di risalita della
montagna paganella che si sta qui dietro
per chiederci
un libro direte voi no un'idea
erano gli anni in cui si cominciava da
prive degli impianti di risalita anche
durante l'estate non solo l'inverno
quando ci sono gli sciatori ed era una
cosa abbastanza difficile bisognava
trovare qualche motivo in più per far
andare gli escursionisti in montagna lei
in realtà un'idea ce l'aveva voleva
portare dei libri in biblioteca
voleva portare un book crossing sapete
quelle piccole casette che uno scambio
libero dei libri
naturalmente uno che arriva in
biblioteca ci fa una proposta di questo
genere insomma fa andare in brodo di
giuggiole i bibliotecari e noi
rilanciamo immediatamente e perché non
una biblioteca vera piccolina ma uguale
alle altre con tutti i servizi che ci
sono a disposizione nelle biblioteche ci
mettiamo d'accordo lo facemmo il luogo
destinato era una radura che sta in
mezzo al bosco
all'arrivo del primo tronco di una
funivia con la stazione di arroccamento
e la partenza del secondo tronco lì
bisognava trovare qualche cosa per
rivitalizzare il posto c'era un
bellissimo ristorante
buonissimo ristorante dove però durante
l'estate non arrivava nessuno
ed è così che abbiamo costruito
all'interno della sala da pranzo del
ristorante la prima biblioteca
abbiamo usato come scaffali le cassette
delle mele quelle di legno abbiamo
costruito degli scaffali che
assomigliavano abbastanza a una delle
città invisibili di calvino e partimmo
naturalmente quella fu l'estate più
piovosa degli ultimi otto secoli
perché la gente si muoveva si in paese
ma non saliva ha fatto in quota però
quelle poche centinaia che salirono
tornavano a casa portandosi un'opinione
bellissima di questa biblioteca
immaginate un po prendere gli impianti
in paese salire a metà montagna trovare
una biblioteca con un ristorante intorno
insomma una figata
e così decidemmo nonostante tutto di
proseguire di investire anche per
l'inverno però bisognava trovare
un'altra idea che ci permettesse di dare
casa alla biblioteca di dare una casa
direttamente sulle piste da sci non
potevamo usare la sala da pranzo e così
pensa pensa pensa trovavano idea shock
avremo realizzato una struttura una
cupola geodetica a forma di igloo alta 5
metri e mezzo con un diametro di 11
metri e l'avremo attrezzata questa volta
in modo
in modo consistente e l'accordo di
gestione era questo
la società di impianti avrebbe gestito
la struttura realizzata curata e
attrezzata tutta spese sue la biblioteca
quindi l'ente pubblico ci avrebbe messo
semplicemente per modo di dire il know
how la capacità di gestire culturalmente
questa struttura naturalmente la società
di impianti aveva bisogno del suo
profitto e quindi e quindi la risalita
fino alle gru sarebbe stata pagamento
anche la partecipazione ai laboratori
creativi sarebbe stata a pagamento ma
facoltativi però volevamo che la
biblioteca fosse gratuita e così avvenne
e quindi ci lavoriamo e a dicembre
troviamo la giornata dell'inaugurazione
troviamo il nome e si apre finalmente il
biblio igloo
immediatamente si crea uno scompiglio
curiosità ma che cosa ci fa una
biblioteca di in mezzo alle piste da sci
molti sciatori si fermavano arrivavano
si fermavano ed entravano molti salivano
dal paese per vedere quello che
succedeva arriva una tv locale che fa un
servizio che viene ripresa
immediatamente dalle agenzie di stampa
di stampa
questa agenzia di stampa passano
l'informazione ai canali nazionali
televisivi e radiofonici e cominciano a
fioccare interviste servizi anche in
programmi di grande e di grande audience
popolare e la curiosità era tanta
insomma trovare una cosa così strana con
un nome così strano libro igloo insomma
era qualcosa che sconvolgeva abbastanza
arriva l'interesse anche dei blogger
turistici anche al di là delle alpi
abbiamo trovato quasi immediatamente che
un blog polacco e un olandese parlavano
del b b le blu come una delle dieci
biblioteche più strane al mondo ma poi
arrivò anche l'interesse culturale
all'università di architettura di lione
in francia ci contattò per chiederci
informazioni sulle gru perché volevano
diffondere in tutti gli atenei francesi
qualche cosa di simile
e poi ha varcato l'oceano e siamo
arrivati perfino in canada pensate voi
in canada il ministero della cultura del
canada una ripartizione che si occupava
di promozione della lettura
propose a tutte le municipalità questo
modulo da diffondere nel territorio
canadese
alla fine arrivò anche un altro
riconoscimento che per noi era grandioso
la fondazione dolomiti unesco che ha in
cura le dolomiti le montagne che abbiamo
intorno venuta a sapere della faccenda e
prese le opportune informazioni ci
assegna il suo patrocinio ed era una
cosa straordinaria unica tutt'oggi
probabilmente sull'altopiano della
paganella
ora da così in alto si possono cadere
nome tantissime belle idee poi alla fine
si affossano da sole per la mancanza di
uno dell'altro degli ingredienti per
fare una buona pietanza e noi invece
abbiamo raddoppiato
sono nove anni che liguria aperto in
questo momento è aperto sulle pendici
della paganella abbiamo raddoppiato
perché da un operatore pagato dalla
società di impianti all'inizio siamo
passati due e anche ai tre e quindi è il
caso di fare velocemente un bilancio e
il bilancio si può fare in due direzioni
il primo è il bilanciamento di tipo
economico e finanziario e allora in due
anni l'investimento fatto dalla società
di impianti sia ammortizzato ed al terzo
anno siamo entrati la società di
impianti entrata in regime di profitto
il ristorante che ci aveva ospitato
nella prima
stagione ha aumentato la sua clientela
ci sono tre persone che vivono di lavoro
culturale e addirittura la località
stessa grazie a tutto il tam tam
mediatico che era stata fatta aveva
aggiunto un tassello in più per
posizionarsi in modo migliore
all'interno del mercato del mercato
turistico ma c'è bisogno anche di fare
un bilancio di tipo culturale
e il bilancio ci dice che noi abbiamo
portato all'igloo almeno 50mila persone
e sono 50 mila persone che magari non
andavano in biblioteca da moltissimo
tempo
o magari non c'erano mai state e avevano
avuto la possibilità di godere di
occasioni culturali
ma poi ci sono stati altri due risultati
strategici il primo è stato quello che
si può definire in termini di advocacy
la comunità residente ha finalmente
cominciato a considerare la biblioteca
come una delle istituzioni che
contribuisce alla crescita del
territorio e non solo in termini di
socialità e di cultura ma anche in
termini economici e poi da un punto di
vista di lobbying le amministrazioni
pubbliche che governano la biblioteca
non solo ci hanno garantito la stabilità
del budget annuo ma addirittura l'anno
incrementata e voi sapete che in questi
ultimi dieci anni le amministrazioni
pubbliche hanno tagliato i fondi sulla
cultura
e allora abbiamo cominciato a chiederci
ma perché il bibliobus funziona così
bene perché lassù in quota spesso
durante l'inverno si arriva ad avere più
utenti che non qui nei paesi avevamo
fatto un'operazione di capovolgimento
non eravamo stati rimasti lì ad
aspettare che la gente entrasse in
biblioteca ma abbiamo portato la
biblioteca dalla gente e poi abbiamo
trovato
con lo sguardo retrospettivo cinque
motivi fondamentali per cui l'igloo
funziona il primo è trasparente
chi sta dentro vede chi sta fuori ma chi
sta fuori vede chi sta dentro e quando
guarda dentro non vede più la polvere
abbiamo abbattuto un muro fisico è una
barriera mentale
il secondo motivo è che
simpatico e divertente
durante l'inverno ci potrete vedere
persone che andrà con le scarponi da sci
con la tuta da neve con il casco in
testa per favore lasciate fuori gli sci
e le racchette ma durante l'estate
potete vedere qualcuno che si porta il
suo animaletto di compagnia
poi è semplice delle cose fantastiche
semplice non vi chiediamo chi siete non
vi chiediamo tessere non numeri di
telefono non chiediamo nulla per entrare
semplicemente uno entra non perché ha
bisogno di un libro ma per chi ha
piacere di stare dentro e di vedere
quello che succede
il quarto motivo è la combinazione
straordinaria di natura e di cultura
vedete che questa è un po la tempesta
perfetta del biblio igloo è per questo
che anche
la fondazione dolomiti unesco ci ha
assegnato il contributo e il patrocinio
ed è per questo che abbiamo formulato
questo claim che anche divertente
1333 libri sul livello del mare perché
siamo convinti che le biblioteche
debbano essere aperte a tutti gli alberi
agli animali e alle persone ma se poi
sono gentili meglio e l'ultimo motivo il
quinto motivo è che di gru è bello è
bello e simbolico un bambino quando
entra l'igloo trova la tana è un'adulta
trova un altro tipo di tana che è
protezione da un tempo troppo veloce la
combinazione di natura e di libro di
cultura ferma il tempo di un individuo e
lo rende più consapevole di sé insomma
eravamo riusciti a fare qualcosa che
assomigliava moltissimo a quello che in
ambito anglosassone si definisce calcio
al place making la trasformazione
estetica di un luogo che diventa
contemporaneamente anche trasformazione
culturale e sociale il caso più famoso
al mondo è quello di londra e degli idea
store che sono biblioteche disseminate
nuove disseminate in giro per la città
nei quartieri più disagiati da un punto
di vista sociale anche criminale e
queste biblioteche che contengono libri
dvd cd musicali contengono tutto quello
che è una biblioteca
alcune di queste hanno anche campetti da
calcio sul tetto per cui i bambini
possono andare a giocare a pallone
oppure macchine da cucire per imparare
taglio cucito oppure possono imparare
una professione
ce n'è un'altra fantastica in italia che
ha fatto calcio laplace making che la
biblioteca di scampia a napoli a cui
siamo particolarmente affezionati
e stata recuperata da cittadini da
associazioni di volontariato in una
palazzina una ex scuola che da ormai da
troppi anni era regno della camorra dove
si spacciava la droga e come dice il suo
direttore
si parte da un libro ma poi si va oltre
si costruisce cittadini e cittadinanza e
le biblioteche possono avere un ruolo
importante
nella crescita di questo paese
ora voi potrete dire che insomma è stata
tutta la somma di una serie di casi
fortunati e in parte lo è stato che
questo poteva avvenire solo qui in
trentino in una zona ricca in realtà non
è così e vi propongo un gioco per
esempio potrete provate a tirar via da
tutto quello che io vi dico che vi ho
detto
il nome andalo paganella trentino e
provate ad immaginare dentro la vostra
testa il nome del vostro paese o della
vostra città
provate a farlo poi tirate via igloo in
mezzo al bosco e metteteci chiatta sul
fiume metterci
palazzina e il tetto di una palazzina
metteteci una chiesa abbandonata o il
parco che semiabbandonato tirate via
addirittura la parola biblioteca e
metteteci museo mostra mostra d'arte
metteteci concerto festival scuola
d'infanzia vedete quante cose potremmo
fare e quante cose potreste fare ognuno
di voi perché se c'è un amministratore
un sindaco un assessore lui ha la
facoltà di fare queste cose se è un
imprenditore privato ha i mezzi per
farlo e se invece un professionista
della cultura ha le competenze per
lavorare in questo senso
e se invece siamo solo normali semplici
cittadini abbiamo voce e tante voci
insieme possono produrre un sogno
perché la biblioteca non è un luogo
comune
la biblioteca è bene comune il bene
comune che sta dentro la biblioteca sono
proprio le persone e le relazioni fra le
persone
la cultura
sta bene in mezzo alla gente
però la gente sta meglio in mezzo alla
cultura
[Applauso]
perdonatemi
questo non l'ho fatto portare per noi la
volevamo stupirvi con effetti speciali
e o un trapano sapete quante cose potete
fare un con un trapano e sapete quante
cose quante persone può servire possono
servirsi di questo trapano una delle
idee che abbiamo per continuare nella
creatività delle biblioteche quella di
trasformare una delle nostre biblioteche
in una biblioteca degli oggetti in una
biblioteca degli attrezzi per cui se
avete un buco da fare nel muro per
prendere un quadro potesse venire in
biblioteca a prendere questo trapano ma
vi presteremo anche una padella per
arrosti dalle caldarroste o una chitarra
per suonare uno scanner ad altissima
definizione una tenda da campeggio
perché vogliamo lavorare non solo sul
bisogno ma sui desideri della gente che
sono quelli che fondano la comunità
allora noi siamo riusciti a fare questo
chissà quante cose riuscite a fare voi
[Applauso]